right now financial institutions are
sort of on everybody's troubled list I
think I would be looking for us strong
financial institutions that I think will
recover with a recovering economy
there's a number of real opportunities
the one unique element of recessions and
difficult times as you create value for
those people who have husband liquidity
and have the resources and the
wherewithal to participate in the
upcoming recovery I'm an optimist I've
seen a number of recessions in my
lifetime heard my parents talk about the
depression but in every stage of
American history we've recovered from
the difficult times an America stronger
more wealthy and more integrated into a
global economy which i think is very
very supportive of of a bright future
for my children and their children as we
go forward
you